من هنا انطلقت شراره التمرد العسكري عند
الثامنه مساء الجمعه تعرض معسكر لقوات
فاغنر في اوكرانيا للقصف والفاعل ليس
الجيش الاوكراني بل الجيش الروسي هذا ما
قاله رئيس المجموعه
ووعد بالانتقام من يقفون وراء ازهاق
ارواحنا اليوم وارواح عشرات الالاف من
الروس سينالون عقابهم ولن يقف احد في
طريقنا حتى تحقيق العداله لقواتنا ولروسيا
كلها في موسكو اخذت التهديدات على محمل
الجد عند الواحده ليلا انتشرت الشرطه
والحرس الوطني امام المباني الحكوميه وفي
هذه الاثناء عبر رجال فاجنر من اوكرانيا
الى روسيا ليلا عند الساعه السابعه صباح
السبت استولوا على روستوف المدينه الروسيه
التي يدير منها الجيش الروسي عملياته في
اوكرانيا
ظهر بريجين الى جانب قاده الروس لا نعرف
ان كانوا يؤيدونه ام انهم مجرد رهائن نريد
ان نقابل رئيس هيئه الاركان وشويجو رئيس
هيئه الاركان ليس هنا سنبقى هنا حتى
نراهما
رئيس هيئه الاركان غراء ووزير الدفاع
شويغو هما من اعلن بيجوجين الحرب ضدهما
داهمت السلطات الروسيه مقر فاجنر في سام
بطرسبورغ وخرج الرئيس الروسي بخطاب قوي
تطرق فيه لحرب 1917
المؤامرات والمشاجرات والسياسات المتبعه
من وراء الجيش والشعب الصدمه الكبيره
وتدمير الجيش وانهيار الدوله وخساره
الاراضي هكذا بدات ماساه الحرب الاهليه
ولن نسمح بتكرارها
استمرت قوات بالتقدم نحو موسكو وعند منتصف
النهار وصلت الى فورونيج على بعد 500
كيلومتر من العاصمه هناك نشابه حريق بسبب
قصف من طائرات الهليكوبتر وبعد ساعات اعلن
عن التوصل الى اتفاق لانهاء التمرد